- We want to build a
company that releases toys
that are educational and entertaining
and we want to do that one
really great toy at a time.
(upbeat music)
My name is Filippo Yacob,
I've always been a big kid,
I've always liked toys,
I've always liked games.
And when I found out that
I was gonna be a father,
I thought it would be a good time
to start making toys for a living.
And I wanted to make educational toys.
I think toys have evolved
from simple objects
of entertainment into tools
for development for children.
Our understanding of how
children develop and grow
has changed the way that we
look at these tools as well
and I think we're at the
point where new kinds of toys
that are truly educational
and entertaining
can start being made
because of technologies
and I just wanted to be
at the forefront of that.
My first toy is called
the Cubetto play set,
it's the most crowdfunded
educational technology
invention in Kickstarter history.
It has won a Red Dog
design award, best of best,
a Cannes Lion Gold for product design,
it's toured the MoMA in
New York City and MIT
and it's a tangible programming
interface for children.
It's a wooden robot that
merges Logo Turtle-inspired
programming with Montessori-based
hands-on learning,
so it's a wooden robot
that children can program
using blocks instead of a screen or text.
I think I'm fairly self-motivated,
I really really wanna make
great products and great toys.
But I think what kind of
gave me the inspiration
and changed my attitude
towards work and design
and life in general was
having my own children.
I have a three-year-old
son who was actually born
on the day that this company was launched.
We would like to see a Cubetto play set
in each of the 2.4 million
or so early-learning centers
and libraries and primary
schools around the world.
And then new products, we have
new products in the pipeline,
new services, and expanding
the range of products
and services that we can
offer to our community
with the same dedication
that we had building this one
and sticking to our principles.